à la pénurie de médicament on va voir le
pharmacien on a une ordonnance ou pas et
on nous dit bah il y a pas bah oui mais
il y a pas mais on fait comment pour se
pour se soigner merci pour nous felous
être avec nous vous êtes pharmacien on
en entend parler depuis la crise du
covid de cette pénuine année déjà qu'on
on a en présence de rupture de
médicamenté ouais et et ça pose de vrais
problèmes de santé parce que le
pharmacien n'a pas ne peut pas honorer
l'ordonnance et on est obligé de
d'envoyer les personnes à d'autres
pharmacies je vous raconterai il y a des
sites qui nous permettent d'orienter les
personnes mais c'est un vrai problème de
santé publicque ouais qui s'arrange pas
en ce moment c'est pour ça qu'on a
décidé d'en parler vos JIT on en parlé
toute la semaine la production
industrielle ne suffit plus la
moxiciline mais aussi les corticoïde ou
encore la fllecaïne manque t à l'appel
on a traversé l'année dernière une
pénurie que tous les Français à certains
niveaux ont connu avec l'expérience de
l'hiver dernier on anticipe les
éventuelles pénuries de médicaments on n
manquera pas si on est tous aussi
responsable ou voilà on est tous alors
réag qu'est-ce qui vous fait réagir bah
tous responsables ça veut dire qu'il
faut aller dans sa pharmacie et ne pas
trop demander de médicaments à priori et
laisser les autres médicaments pour les
autres oui mais il a un moment quand on
a une ordonnance et on a besoin de ces
traitements j'ai entendu la flécaïne on
en a pas donc responsable ou pas là pour
le coup il n'y en a pas donc il faut
appeler les médecins essayer de
substituer la flécaïne qui est un
médicament quand même important pour
pour certaines personnes c'est quoi
c'est c'est quoi comme type de
médicament bah aujourd'hui ce qui manque
il manque un peu tout il manque beaucoup
de produit c'estàd ça non mais par
exemple la moxyiline pardon ça c'est un
anti distribué qui qui très
régulièrement par les méc c'est même pas
qui manque des antibiotiques c'est que
on a des problèmes d'approvisionnement
aujourd'hui on a essayé de trouver un
système et le problème c'est que on est
contingenté sur les médicaments c'estàd
qu'on ne peut pas en commander autant
qu'on veut et c'est ça le problème c'est
que l'État nous nous impose des
quantités au niveau de la distribution
mais on peut pas répondre à toute la
population donc on est confronté à une
vraie pénurie et à une vraie délivrance
pour essayer de soigner les personnes va
fa trouver des solutions Floriant ouioui
bah moi je travaille beaucoup sur sur le
sujet en ce moment parce que je prépare
un papier qui sera dans VSD à la fin du
mois justement non mais c'est c'est
vraiment un sujet dit qu' bosse je bosse
vraiment le sujet il y a un livre qui
sort d'ailleurs le mois prochain qui
s'appelle votre santé va vous couperom
c'est pas mon livre c'est juste que je
viens de le recevoir et c'est
passionnant et juste on explique un tr
TR tout simple c'est que le manque de
médicament c'est aussi lié à la
mondialisation c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
il y a des tas de substances qui sont
fabriquées en Inde en Chine et le fait
de ne plus avoir ces substances qui
arrivent on peut plus fabriquer les
médicaments et on parle beaucoup des
dolipran AL doliprane c'est chouette
sauf qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de
médicamentens pour le cancer pour le
diabète pour les problèmes de rein et
cetera et c'est ceux-là qui sont les
plus graves et en l'espace de 3 4 ans le
manque a été multiplié par je crois
trois ou quatre donc moi c'est ce que
j'ai découvert et c'est complètement fou
quoi c'est vraiment qui n ATT et puis
aussi a les co de fabrication
aujourd'hui faut pas oublier que les
laboratoires vendent leur médicaments à
chaque pays en France le prix du
médicament à l'achat pour la France
n'est pas assez cher et beaucoup moins
cher que le coût de fabrication donc les
laboratoires préfèrent le vendre à à
d'autres pays d'Europe en Allemagne
l'année dernière n'oubliez pas que
l'Allemagne pour acheter les médicaments
ont augmenté le prix du médicament pour
que les labo puisse profiter de leur
vendre à eux en France on n pas touché
au prix donc les labos préfèrent vendre
à d'autres pays bah pour financièrement
classique donc al on se sort comment
Bruno felous parce que là ça fait des
années que ça dure c'est la course aux
antibiotiques on fait toutes les
pharmacies pour pouvoir honorer
l'ordonnance du du médecin de dolipran
mais Simp on citer dolipran mais mais il
y a pas que le doliprane on a eu des
problèmes de de doliprane
paracéamol parce que le paracéamol a eu
une forte demande pendant le covid et je
vous rappelle que pendant le covid
c'était le traitement
mag cétait en 2020 confinement là on est
en 2023 c'est toujours pas résolu il y a
une forte demande il y a eu des
problèmes dans le labo mais bon ça s
réglé aujourd'hui c'est même pas le
doliprane c'est vraiment des traitements
lourds comme vous avez dit mais les
hypertenseurs les antibiotiques les
cortisones il y a des crèmes je vous dis
le problème c'est que on narrive pas à
se fournir c'est pas qu'il y en a pas
attention il y en a c'est juste que le
le coût de fabrication le coût d'achat
la le manque de de stock pour l'État
français et derrière l'État qui qui nous
qui nous oblige à ne pas trop commander
pour laisser aux autres pharmacies
normal est-ce que c'est un problème
spécifique à la France ou c'est mondial
aujourd'hui c'est spécifique à la France
le coût de l'inflation on a essayé de
chercher les médicaments les moins chers
donc on a été s'approvisionné dans des
pays où il y avait des excipiants des
principes actifs qui étaient pas chers
sauf que quand vous retrouvez le
fournisseur seul d'un principe actif
dans le monde à un moment vous êtes
obligé d'augmenter les coûts h parce que
le transport toutes ces chosesl la
solution c'est pas de réindustrialiser
en France tout simplement are problème
ça parce que le le cûp ne sera pas le
même puisque on connait les charges en
France comment ça se passe mais ça
serait la meilleure solution mais il
faudra mettre un petit peu même beaucoup
d'argent sur la table donc c'est pas une
solution immédiate non ça va durer
combien de temps écoute ça fait un an et
quelques mois pourquoi pas on a
l'habitude que ça continue encore hein
on n pas et puis c'est les personnes qui
réfléchissent pour nous sont pas très
logiques excusez-moi de vous le dire il
on a un vrai problème làdessus oui
divine c'est vrai que c'est un maronnier
mainant cette pénurie de médicament l'an
dernier on était surtout sur les les les
médicaments antigrippaux antituif je me
rappelle qu'il fallait moi que je
m'approvisionne aux Antilles pour des
sirops contre laatou tellement il y en
avait plus dans les pharmacies ici en
France à qui profite le crime en fait
pourquoi ça pourquoi ça continue
pourquoi c'est ça change de médicament
chaque année en fait on est sur nouveau
il privilégi leur chaîne de fabrication
en fin de compte le sirop il en a manqué
l'année dernière cette année il y en
aura mais derrière il va manquer autre
chose ils essayent de c'est c'est les
ches musical on va dire ils essaient
d'approvisionner au maximum mais à un
moment on et encore là on n'est pas
rentré dans les épidémies hivernales et
hivern hivernal
pardon juste un mot aussi ou Pascal il y
a peut-être aussi un problème au niveau
des pharmarmacie c'est que moi j'ai
découvert qu'une commune de de moins de
2500 habitants ne pouvait pas avoir de
pharmacie donc il faut aussi pouvoir les
trouver les médicaments fa aussi trouver
une pharmacie à côté de chez soi le
territoire français est assez maillé en
en pharmacie il y a 22500 pharmacies en
France franchement quand on est dans une
zone un désert médical on va en parler
enfin désert médical c'estme aussi un
point très important on l'a pas évoqué
c'est les enfants je moi j'ai une petite
fille de 3 ans et demi elle a été comme
tous les enfants de cet âge là plusieurs
fois malade cette année à chaque fois
l'antibiotique qu'on lui a prescrit je
l'ai pas trouvé bah oui c'est on en
revient à la pénurine médicament mais
alors attendez pardon vous pouvez pas
vous mettre d'accord avec les médecins
tout simplement pour non mais attendez
non mais super de de prcrire de la
moxyiline je cite cet antibiotique en le
Pharma travaille avec le médecin pour lu
donner la liste pour le médecin vous
prescrit de la mocicyine alors qu'il
sait pertinemment qu' qu'on trouver pas
antibiotique est utilisé pour une
pathologie alors c'est mais il y a pas
d'autres antibiotiques qui peuvent per
certain anti en rupture ou et puis on
peut pas donner n'importe quel type
d'antibiotique pour n'importe quel type
de maladie donc on se sur Lesire ça ça
on marche sur la tête ça qu'on en France
en 2023 on ne trouve plus les
antibiotiques oui qui vont permettre de
de guérir des des maladies après
l'antibiotique n'est pas systématique on
le sait bien sr c'est
vousr oigatoire on est d'accord mais on
peut pas répondre à la demande c'est ça
qui est horrible et là je vais vous
parlermi c'est que là il y a un vaccin
qui est sorti il y a pas longtemps pour
la broncholite des
[Musique]
enfants en 15 jours il y a plus de il y
a plus de vaccin c'est pas la première
fois qu'il y a des pineries en les
années 70 c'était déjà le cas il y a une
augmentation ces dernières années et il
y a certains pays qui mettent en place
des réserves nationales on devrait pas y
venir tout simplement mais c'est pour ça
que l'État aujourd'hui compte les
médicaments pour les pharmaciens et je
ne peux pas en commander autant que je
veux donc je suis restreint à avoir 20
30 boîtes par mois d' de certains
médicens qui s'écoule en 40 72 he et
c'est ça la catastrophe c'est que là on
n pas on n'est pas dans en hiver où il y
a pas de de pathologie grave on va dire
mais quand on va rentrer dans l'hiver
avec toutes les petites lesbobologie la
pathologie on va se retrouver en en 2 3
jours en peignerie donc donc mais alors
donc il y a pas de solution je ne sais
pas alors alors en fait on fait un état
des lieux si vous nous regardez on fait
un état des lieux ce soir il y a pas de
il y a pas de solution pour l'instant on
n pas de solution les le gouvernement a
réfléchi la la semaine dernière à nous
mettre à déconditionner les médicaments
ce qui est complètement aberrent
aujourd'hui parce que quoi décition dé
conditionition c'estàd qu'on ouvre la
boîte oui tu donnes trois donner juste
ce qui a prcrit par le M exactement sauf
que les labos ont travaillé depuis 10
ans et les les en général les boîtes de
médicaments les boîtes d'antibiotiques
correspondent à la posologie du
traitement sur sur 6 jours 7 jours donc
vous allez vous retrouver avec par
exemple la moxicine c'est des boîtes de
14 correspondant à 7 jours donc il y a
même pas besoin de la déconditionner et
surtout ça fait 10 ans qu'on travaille
sur la sérialisation ce qui est un ce
qui ce qui nous permet de suivre la vie
du médicament donc de le
déconditionnement n'est pas possible
parce que il y a la traçabilité est
cassée donc c'est on peut pas
déconditionner est-ce que vous avez pas
un risque vous devez en voir vous des
clients qui viennent et qui vous disent
je voudrais 10 boîtes de doliprane pour
faire des stocks non mais c'est vrai
tout le monde a perd monur t le problème
est là aussi et vous vous avez pas le
droit de dire non alors on essaie de
restreindre un petit peu pour voir le
stock alors nous aussi on compte un
jantere nos clients en vérité puisque le
stock s'épuise et on fait attention bon
bon faites attention bon il y a pas de
solution vous reviendrez Bruno parce que
je suis sûr qu'on va en entendre parler
encore notamment cet hiver de ce manque
de de médicament sourit mais enfin on a
t on est tous insofi on a on est tous
confrontés à ça on marche sur la tête
enfin faut quand même trouver une
solution il y a qu'en France est-ce que
vous me dites il y a qu'en France que ça
ça fonctionne comme ça trouver des
solutions augmenter le prix de l'achat
c'est tout c'est c'est très simple il
faut juste augmenter le prix d'achat et
que les labos puissent reprendre leur
commerce sur l'état français merci
beaucoup Bruno F être revenenous sur le
plateau de Paf ce soir merci beaucoup
vous reviendrait évidemment on va